so we are
simultaneously working on a paper on
schizophrenia right now
that is basically using the single cell
profiling technologies using this
editing and manipulation technologies
to basically show how the
master regulators underlying changes in
the brain
that are sort of found in in
schizophrenia are in fact
affecting excitatory neurons and
inhibitory neurons in pathways
that are active both in synaptic pruning
but also in early development we've
basically found a set of four regulators
that are connecting these two processes
that were previously separate
in schizophrenia in sort of having
a sort of more unified view across those
two those two sides
the second one is in the in the area of
metabolism we basically now have a
beautiful collaboration with the
goodyear lab that's basically looking at
um multi-tissue perturbations
in six or seven different tissues across
the body
in the context of exercise and in the
context of nutritional
interventions using both mouse and human
where we can basically see what are the
cell to cell communications
that are that are changing across them
and what we're finding is this
immense role of both immune cells as
well as
adipocyte stem cells in sort of
reshaping that circuitry
of all of these different tissues and
that's sort of painting to a new path
for therapeutical interventions there
in alzheimer's it's this huge focus on
microglia
and now we're discovering different
classes of microglial cells
that are basically either synaptic or
immune and these are playing
vastly different roles in alzheimer's
versus in schizophrenia
and what we're finding is this immense
complexity
as you go further and further down of
how in fact there's 10 different types
of microglia
each with their own sort of expression
programs we used to think of them as oh
yeah they're microglia
but in fact now we're realizing just
even in that sort of
least abundant of cell types there's
this incredible diversity there
the differences between brain regions is
is another sort of major major insight
again
you know one would think that oh
astrocytes are astrocytes no matter
where they are but no there's
incredible region-specific differences
in the expression patterns
of all of the major brain cell types
across different brain regions
so basically there's the neocortical
regions that are sort of the recent
innovation that makes us so
different from all other species there's
the sort of you know reptilian brain
sort of regions that are sort of much
more
uh you know very extremely distinct
there's a cerebellum
there's um each of those basically is
associated in a different way
with disease and what we're doing now is
looking into
pseudotemporal models for how disease
progresses
across different regions of the brain if
you look at alzheimer's it basically
starts in this
small region called the enterinal cortex
and then it spreads
through the brain and uh you know
through the hippocampus and
you know the uh ultimately affecting the
neocortex and with every brain region
that it hits
it basically has a different impact on
the uh
cognitive and you know memory aspects
orientation
short-term memory long-term memory etc
which is
you know dramatically affecting the
cognitive path that the individuals go
through
so what we're doing now is uh creating
these computational models for ordering
the cells and the regions and the
individuals
according to their ability to predict
alzheimer's disease
so we can have a cell level predictor
of pathology that allows us to now
create
a temporal time course that tells us
when every gene turns on along
this pathology progression and then
trace that across
regions and pathological measures that
are region-specific
but also cognitive measures and so forth
so
that allows us to now sort of for the
first time look at can we actually do
early intervention for alzheimer's
where we know that the disease starts
manifesting for 10 years before
you actually have your first cognitive
loss
can we start seeing that path to build
new diagnostics new prognosis new
biomarkers
for this sort of early intervention in
alzheimer's
the other aspect that we're looking at
is mosaicism we talked about the common
variance and the rare variance
but in addition to those rare variants
as your
initial cell that that forms a zygote
divides and divides and divides
with every cell division there are
additional mutations that are happening
so what you end up with is your brain
being a mosaic
of multiple different types of genetic
underpinnings some cells
contain imitation that other cells don't
have
so every human has the
common variant that all of us carry to
some degree
the rare variant that your immediate
tree of the human species carries
and then there's the somatic variant
which is the tree
that happened after the zygote that sort
of forms your own body
so these somatic alterations is
something that has been previously
inaccessible
to study in human post-mortem samples
but right now
with the advent of single cell rna
sequencing in this particular case we're
using the well-based sequencing which is
much more expensive but gives you a lot
richer information
about each of these transcripts so we're
using now that richer information
to infer mutations that have happened
in each of the thousands of genes that
sort of are active
in these cells and then understand
how the genome relates
to the function this genotype
phenotype relationship that we usually
build in geos between
genome-wide association studies between
genetic variation and disease
we're now building that at the cell
level where for
every cell we can relate the unique
specific genome of that cell
with the expression patterns of that
cell and the predicted function
using these predictive models that i
mentioned before on this regulation for
cognition for pathology
in alzheimer's at the cell level and
what we're finding is that
the genes that are altered and the
genetic regions that are altered
in common variants versus rare variants
versus somatic variants
are actually very different from each
other the somatic variants are pointing
to
neuronal energetics and oligodendrocyte
functions
that are not visible in the genetic
lesions that you find for the common
variants
probably because they have too strong of
an effect that evolution is just not
tolerating them
on the common side of the allele
frequency spectrum so the somatic one
that's the variation that happens after
the the zygo after
correct are you individual i mean it's a
dumb question but
there's there's mutation and variation i
guess that happens there
and you're saying that they're through
this if we focus in on individual cells
we're able to detect a story
that's interesting there and that might
be a very unique
kind of important variability that
arises
for you said neuronal or something
energetic energetics energetic cool
terms so you're you're
i mean the metabolism of humans is
dramatically altered from that of
nearby species you know we talked about
that last time that basically we are
able to consume meat
that is incredibly energy rich and that
allows us to sort of have functions
that are you know meeting this humongous
brain that we have
so basically on one hand every one of
our brain cells is much more energy
efficient than our neighbors than our
relatives
number two we have way more of these
cells and
number three we have you know this
new diet that allows us to now feed all
these needs that basically creates a
massive amount of
damage oxidative damage from this
huge super powered factory of ideas and
thoughts that we that we carry in our
skull and that
factory has energetic needs and there's
a lot of sort of biological processes
underlying that
that we are finding are altered in the
context of alzheimer's disease that's
fascinating that so you have to consider
all of these systems if you want to
understand
even something like diseases that you
would maybe traditionally associate with
just
the particular cells of the brain yeah
the immune system
the metabolic system the metabolic
system and these are all the
things that makes us uniquely human so
our immune system is dramatically
different from that of our neighbors
our societies are so much more clustered
the history of infections that have
plagued
the human population is you know
dramatically different from every other
species
the the you know the way that our
society in our population has sort of
exploded
has basically put unique pressures on
our immune system and our immune system
has both coped with that density and
also been shaped
by as i mentioned the you know vast
amount of death
that has happened in the in the black
plague and other sort of selective
events
in human history famines ice ages so so
forth
so that's number one on on the sort of
immune side on the metabolic side
you know again we are able to sort of
run marathons
you know you know i don't know if you
remember the sort of human versus horse
experiment
where the horse actually tires out
faster than the human and the human
actually wins
um so on the metabolic side we're
dramatically different
on the immune side we're dramatically
different on the brain side again
you know no need to sort of you know
it's a no-brainer how
our brain is like just enormously more
capable
and then uh in you know in the side of
cancer so basically the cancers that
humans
are having the exposure the
environmental exposures is
again dramatically different and the
lifespan the expansion of human lifespan
is unseen in any other species in
you know recent uh evolutionary history
and that now leads to a lot of new
disorders
that are starting to you know manifest
late in life so uh you know alzheimer's
is one example where basically you know
these vast energetic needs
over a lifetime of thinking can
basically lead to all of these debris
and eventually saturate the system and
lead to
you know alzheimer's in in the late life
but there's you know there's just such a
such a dramatic
uh set of frontiers when it comes to
aging research
that you know will so what i often like
to say is that
if you want to re to to engineer a car
to go from 70 miles an hour to 120 miles
an hour that's fine
you can basically you know fix a few
components if you wanted to now go at
400 miles an hour
you have to completely redesign the
entire car
because the system has just not evolved
to go that far basically our human body
has only evolved to live to i don't know
maybe we can get to 150 with minor
changes
but if you know as we start pushing
these frontiers for not just living but
well living the f zine that we talked
about last time
so to basically push f zine into the 80s
and 90s and 100s and
you know much further than that we will
face new challenges that have you know
never been faced before in terms of
cancer the number of divisions in terms
of alzheimer's and brain related
disorders
in terms of metabolic disorders in terms
of regeneration
there's just so many different frontiers
ahead of us so
i am thrilled about where we're heading
so basically i see this confluence
in my lab and many other labs of ai
of you know sort of you know the next
frontier of ai for drug design so
basically these
sort of graph neural networks on
specific chemical designs that allow you
to
create new generations of therapeutics
this
molecular biology tricks for intervening
at the system at every level
this personalized medicine prediction
diagnosis and prognosis using the
electronic health records
and using these polygenic risk scores
weighted
by the burden the number of mutations
that are accumulating across common rare
and somatic variants
the burden converging across all of
these different
molecular pathways the delivery
of specific drugs and specific
interventions into specific cell types
and again you've talked with bob langer
about this there's you know many giants
in that field
and then the last concept is not
intervening at the single gene
level i want you to sort of uh
conceptualize the concept of an
on target side effect
what is an on-target side effect an
off-target side effect
is when you design a molecule to target
one gene and instead it targets another
gene and you have side effects because
of that
an on target side effect is when your
molecule does exactly what you're
expecting
but that gene is pliotropic plio means
many
tropos means ways many ways it acts in
many ways
it's a multifunctional gene so you find
that this gene plays a role in this but
as we talked about
the wiring of genes to phenotypes is
extremely dense and extremely complex
so the next stage of intervention will
be
intervening not at the gene level but at
the network level
intervening at the set of pathways and
the set of genes with
multi-input perturbations to the system
multi-input modulations
pharmaceutical or other interventional
that basically allow you to now work at
the
sort of full level of understanding not
just in your brain but across your body
not just in one gene but across the set
of pathways and so and so forth
for every one of these disorders so i
think that we're finally at the level of
systems medicine
of basically instead of sort of medicine
being at a single gene level
medicine being at the systems level
where it can be personalized
based on a specific set of genetic
markers and genetic perturbations that
you are
either born with or that you have
developed during your lifetime
your unique set of exposures your unique
set of biomarkers
and you know your unique set of you know
current set of conditions through your
ehr and other ways
and the precision component
of intervening extremely precisely in
the specific pathways
and specific combinations of genes that
should be modulated to sort of bring you
from the disease state
to the physiologically normal state or
even to a physiologically improved state
through this combination of intervention
so that that's in my view the field
where basically computer science comes
together
with you know artificial intelligence
statistics all of these other tools
molecular biology technologies and
biotechnology and pharmaceutical
technologies that are sort of
revolutionary
the way of intervention and of course
this massive amount of molecular biology
and data gathering and generation
perturbation in massively parallel ways
so there's no better way
there's no better you know time there's
no better
place to be sort of you know looking at
this whole confluence
of of ideas and i'm just so thrilled to
be
a small part of this amazing enormous
ecosystem
it's exciting to imagine what the humans
of 100 200 years from now
what their life experience is like
because
these ideas seem to have potential to
transform the quality of life
that when they look back at us
they probably wonder how we were put up
with all the suffering
in the world
you